Німецька компанія Deutsche Bahn - не лише найбільший оператор
і власник залізничної інфраструктури у Німеччині та Європі,
а й посідає третє місце у світі за повітряними
та морськими перевезеннями вантажів.
Концерн також активно будує, проектує і консультує за межами ФРН,
маючи спільні проекти у понад ста країнах світу.
Deutsche Bahn представлений на всіх континентах.
Приміром, у Сполучених Штатах німці беруть участь в розробці
швидкісного залізничного сполучення
між Сан-Франциско та Лос-Анджелесом.
Планується, що відстань між цими містами
у Каліфорнії у понад 600 кілометрів
можна буде здолати менш, ніж за три години.
В Австралії ж Deutsche Bahn задіяний у будівництві
першої в країні повністю автоматизованої системи метрополітену.
В Індії - 26-кілометрової надземної лінії метро.
А в столиці Катару місті Доха
наприкінці минулого року
вже відкрили першу лінію метро, яка з’єднує
східну та західну частини міста і збудована
за участі німецького концерну.
Катар і Deutsche Bahn мають також спільний багатомільярдний проект
з будівництва залізниць у цій близькосхідній країні.
Німці займаються плануванням спорудження транспортної системи Катару.
Це 350 кілометрів далекого залізничного сполучення
і 300 кілометрів - приміського, включно з метро
у столичному регіоні.
Deutsche Bahn фактично має 180 років залізничного досвіду і може консультувати,
робити експертизу, проектувати та реалізовувати інфраструктурні проекти
від етапу зародження ідеї до її реалізації.
За оцінками експертів, приблизно
мільйон кілометрів залізничних шляхів у світі
вже придатний для оцифровування.
Тож нині Deutsche Bahn розробляє системи для так званого
прогнозного обслуговування та моніторингу транспортної інфраструктури.
Облаштовуються ось такі чекпойнти для збирання інформації
про рухомі частини потягів.
Наприклад, якщо колеса потребують обслуговування чи заміни,
система одразу це виявить.
Так само можна буде стежити за якістю самих залізничних колій й оперативно ремонтувати їх.
Вже в недалекому майбутньому коли потяг повертатиметься в ангар,
ось так з планшета можна буде робити
діагностику його стану.
Активно у Deutsche Bahn починають використовувати й дрони, які роблять
фото високої якості для вимірювання та оцінки тієї чи іншої ділянки під будівництво
Це значно швидше і менш витратно порівняно
з великою командою фахівців з традиційними приборами.
У Deutsche Bahn є своя залізнична академія DB Rail
з програмою навчання та підвищення кваліфікації
для залізничного і загалом транспортного секторів.
У компанії запевняють, що формують інфраструктуру майбутнього,
зважаючи на безпеку, інновації та захист навколишнього середовища.
Проекти Deutsche Bahn за кордоном не завжди відзначаються лише успіхом.
У 2013 році концерн вирішив припинити діяльність
у деяких державах,
охарактеризувавши їх як країни з високим рівнем корупції.
Мова йшла, зокрема, про Грецію, Алжир і Таїланд.
Підставою для цього стали результати розслідування франкфуртської прокуратури,
гідно з якими дочірнє підприємство концерну DB International
платило у деяких країнах хабарі, щоб отримати
замовлення на консультації і планування залізничних проектів.
Приміром, стверджувалось, що у Греції під час будівництва метро
на підкуп замовників було спрямовано 315 тисяч євро.
Після цього скандалу Deutsche Bahn звільнив понад 30 співробітників,
зокрема і низку керівників.
Нині у концерні запевняють,
що ретельно перевіряють усі замовлення та угоди.